Building connected
devices is hard enough,
but once you've got
your device running,
the really hard work begins.
How do you make it easy for your
users to get onto the network?
Or interact with it from mobile
apps or your web service?
Or even give other
developers the ability
to include it in more
apps and services?
Hi, I'm Timothy Jordan, and this
is an introduction to Weave.
Weave helps you focus on adding
intelligence into the user
experience in two ways.
By giving you all
the building blocks
you need for communicating
with your devices directly
or through the cloud, and by
providing a common language
for your app or service
to use across all
of the user's devices.
Specifically, Weave
provides a protocol
for device discovery,
provisioning, authentication,
and interaction.
This protocol is implemented
across a device-side library,
mobile SDKs, and
a web service that
enables remote interactions.
A Weave implementation typically
involves three components.
First, the device itself.
And this is what ends
up on store shelves.
You'll add Weave functionality
by including a library that
handles a lot of the
implementation details,
such as the protocol.
This makes it easy
for you let your users
interact with your device
locally or remotely.
And by the way,
the integration is
easiest if you use
the Brillo operating
system, where the Weave library
is built in and maintained
directly.
Once you've integrated
the library,
you'll add support
for a schema, which
are commands in state that are
common for your device type
and customized or extended for
your product in particular.
This makes it easy
for apps and services
to interact with your device.
And if you're not building
a device, don't worry.
You can still build
apps and services
that use Weave to make
device interactions easier.
We'll get to that in a minute.
Next, the cloud service.
This enables communication
between the user and the device
when they're not in proximity
or on the same network.
You don't have to write
any specific code for this.
It's already handled for
you by the Weave library.
And because this
is in place, you
can see aggregated
metrics in the developer
console to help you
better understand
your universe of devices.
And finally, there are
client apps and services
on the user's mobile
phone, desktop, or the web.
These are where users go
to set up and interact
with your devices.
And the setup experience
is quick and easy.
The user can initiate a
secure setup experience
common to all Weave devices
that works from both Android
and iOS.
It's especially nice on
Android because the flow
ends with the option
to install your app.
After set up, if you
want your app or service
to talk to your device,
all you need to do
is use the local or cloud API.
They'll allow you to
communicate with the device
to get state or send commands,
whether from the same network,
or halfway around the world.
One more thing.
Your apps and services
can communicate
with Weave devices made
by other developers,
too, using the same
standardized schemas.
This makes it easy to
build richer experience
around your devices and how
they fit into users lives,
regardless of the underlying
hardware, make, or model.
And that's a quick overview
of Weave, its components,
and how they fit together.
We're excited to see what
you'll build with it.
Here's a link to help
you get started today.
Oh, and please be sure
to send us feedback so
that together, we can
make Weave the easiest way
to connect all the things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]